I thought the last 30 days of high
school senior year last 30 days was the
weirdest phenomenon which was everyone
was in her clicks and out of nowhere
after three and seven eighth years of
everyone living in their own worlds
everyone kind of came together and
intermingled I remember that too though
actually everyone's coming together at
the end I watched it consistently when I
got into High School the three grades
above me and I had two younger siblings
it happened for them I stayed very close
to this concept I used to have this
movie titled the last 30 days and it was
the last 30 days of high school I I I'm
probably gonna make it yeah
I'm probably gonna make it